this is all that remains of the bear
lakes estates in phoenix in oregon
all but wiped out by one of those dozens
of fires burning across the state
investigators are looking into whether
the fire that did this
was started deliberately
whatever the initial cause these fires
are being fueled
by strong dry winds already more than
double the average amount of land that
burns each year
has been destroyed half a million people
almost
10 percent of the state's population are
now under evacuation orders
search teams are only now reaching some
of the communities that have been
destroyed
they expect to find that more people
have died
the town of tallant suffered extensive
damage nicole brown
made it through the fire here we kept an
eye on the neighborhood
we we've seen a lot of people kind of
trespassing through the neighborhood
that's kind of why i wanted to stay home
i was concerned and
just kept watering down my my yard and
my roof
and stayed there all night this map
tells the story of the western united
states right now
not just oregon but up and down the
coast in washington state stephen biles
was driving home
when he saw a grass fire closing in on
houses
get out of your house
everybody get back i'm so sorry ma'am
you got to grab your stuff we got to go
firefighters were unable to save these
houses
further south in california they're more
used to these fires
but that makes it no easier the state's
governor says the death and damage and
the hardest hit
butte county is a warning the hots are
getting a lot
hotter the dries are getting a lot drier
and the wets are getting a lot wetter
that's climate change that's what the
scientists predicted that's the reality
that we're experiencing here in the
state of california we have to
own that reality and we have to own a
response to that reality
the weather forecast is at last offering
some hope to firefighters that they can
begin to contain these fires
but they're taking nothing for granted
this summer has been a reminder of the
speed and devastation of these fires
that no one needed greg milam sky news
los angeles